بس بس دكتور خلينا حتى لانه لانه اليوم
هذه التقنيه ما
بينك اللي هو التبخيض بسائل وما بين ايضا
تسخين السجائر اللي هي من غير من غير
اشعالها وبالتالي حرق صح صح هذه هذه اللي
هي التسخين يقول لك لا هذه ما فيها مشكله
الرئه اللي تحصل مع فبالتالي من الممكن ان
تكون هي التي تكون الصحيه او تحمل
الفيتامينات خلينا بس نوضح مساله معينه هي
منين اجت ترويج انه السيجاره والتدخين
السيجاره العاديه بتحتوي على 7000 ماده
ضار ليس النيكوتين فقط وليس القطران
ومنها مثل ما بنعرف الامونيا
والكرب اللي هني مواد ضاره جدا
الترويج للسياره الالكترونيه قالت انه
هالمواد مش موجوده فيه فيها ولكن
اثبت لحد هلا الفورمه مثلا المواد
المسرطنه موجوده بالسياره الالكترونيه
اللي كنت الفكره اللي بدي اوضحها انه في
سهوله بالتدخين للاسف هلا المشكله مثلا
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه عملوا
دراسه لقوا تلاميذ
هني الاكثر
يعني عم يدخنوا بالمدارس
للاسف وبيقدروا يخفوها من غير السيجاره ما
الها دول اوروبيه تسمح لك تدخنها في
المجمعات التجاريه في في اماكن مغلقه
فبالتالي هي اليوم اصبح حقيقه الخطوه
الاستراليه هي بدايه الحظر بدل الهيئات
الصحيه وبتصور حنتبع هالمسار هيدا ونلاقي
عشر سنين
وسجائر الفيتامينات بس على كل حال للاسف
انتهى وقتنا يمكن نتحدث بشكل مفصل في
حلقات قادمه الدكتور منصور طبعا كان معنا
الاخصائي في امراض الجهاز
التنفسي وطب العنايه المركزه شكرا لك
دكتور لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات